Oh
good morning everyone we will start our
session
and those full speaker is James Paulo
who is a patent developer with our
experience in developing in but I guess
and he's going to talk about generators
of it Python so good morning everyone
my task with this session is to raise
the energy level in here a little bit I
can tell you that my energy level is a
little bit low because I was up till 3
a.m. last night writing a little bit of
code I think we all find ourself in that
situation the talk you're about to hear
has some theoretical or conceptual
content but I should say as a reminder
that as programmers our job is to create
these code artifacts that do something
useful so I just wanted to share with
you a little code artifact that kept me
up all night I sit in a lot of meetings
and I have to schedule a lot of meetings
so I thought in 50 lines of code can I
write a little tool that will help me
figure out how to coordinate meetings so
I wrote this little guy
it took me about 3-4 hours to get this
but you can see you know you can put in
the different time zones you can search
the time zones and go forward and
backwards in time and I thought that's
kind of neat so that's an example of
something practical and useful that we
can actually accomplish with code so
let's get into the theoretical the title
of this talk is generators will free
your mind I'll give you a brief
introduction of myself and then we'll
dive right in I'm James Powell as you
can probably hear I'm from outside of
Germany I'm actually from Texas I live
and work in New York City the notes for
this talk if you're interested are on
github at D UTC that's my handle you can
find me under this name through all over
the internet d UTC stands for don't use
this code I thought I'd put the
disclaimer up front and center so I'm
James and don't use this code calm I'm
at don't use this code on Twitter I have
a blog at seriously that don't use this
code calm on IRC I camp out on many of
the different channels
like the Python channel a positive
Python channel on IRC I'm D UTC if
that's available for don't use this code
if that's not I'm from Texas so I'll add
an H on the end and I'll be there as
Dutch for don't use this code Hoss come
on I gotta raise the energy level a
little bit here I usually attend these
events representing a meetup group that
I run NYC Python in my spare time I
actually have a real job I work for the
Python quads we ran a conference in
March to show you a little bit about and
I have a couple of jokes to get like get
everything started I just want to show
you a couple of interesting things and
to let you know of some events that are
coming up outside of Germany this is the
meetup group that I run NYC Python it's
a group that I'm exceptionally proud of
it is the largest and most active Python
meetup group in the world
we crossed 5,500 members we have four
weekly events two biking weekly events
every other Thursday it is amazing and
it is intense one of the things that
we're doing this summer is we're hosting
a regional conference in new york new
york skipped the regional conference in
2013 hi Gotham is on for 2014 it's in
three weeks time we are all completely
stressing out and freaking out about
putting this on but it looks like you
know it's going to be an absolute blast
it's going to be amazing so if you have
an opportunity or if you're going to be
in New York in this timeframe you
definitely definitely definitely need to
attend PAGASA
it's going to be really really cool the
reason that we took upon ourselves the
ambition to run a conference was that
separate from the meetup group and
separate from NYC Python I actually ran
my own conference in March of this year
called for Python quads and some of the
speaker's here today were speaking there
you can see this guy somewhere in the
back of the room and it was a event for
finance professionals who wanted to talk
about the application of Python to
problems in the financial industry it
looks like for Python cons we'll be back
maybe this year in London so follow me
on Twitter for news but there may be
news about another Python quants event
the Python quants is a consulting
services and product company for finding
in the financial analytics space one of
the things that we do is we build
analytics and infrastructure for hedge
funds this is an example of a fund that
we're building all the infrastructure
analytics for additionally we have a
really cool platform called the python
quants platform go to quant platform
comm now some of you may recognize me
the first PI data talk I gave was at PI
data New York 2012 and then I spoke at
PI data Silicon Valley 2013 then I spoke
at PI data Boston 2013 then New York
2013 then London 2014 then Silicon
Valley 2014 and this is the seventh PI
data conference I've spoken at and I've
given the same talk every single time I
actually know there's some new material
for you today and I really hope you
enjoy but to get the new mood started I
want to share with you a couple of jokes
I I couldn't really calibrate the amount
of seriousness for the audience so I put
in three jokes to get you guys warmed up
just in case you need it so have you
guys heard the one about the broken
pencil never mind it's pointless that's
that's weak okay we got another one what
do you get when you cross a joke with a
rhetorical question
that's a punchline in itself and then
finally what's the difference between
ignorance and apathy I don't know and I
don't care okay with that aside okay we
got a little bit of energy out of you
guys let's see if we can plow through
that the title of this talk is
generators will free your mind and the
broad themes of what I want to talk
about our code as an artifact that's in
motion code isn't a static artifact it's
something that evolves over time as the
needs of the problem the code is
addressed to solve change that
generators are a very useful mechanism
for modeling these problems that we can
use generators to build models for our
problems that are fundamentally
different from other poaches that we
take and these approaches can produce
very meaningfully different results and
then finally I wanted to touch upon a
topic that is very dear to my heart
which is the need in our industry for a
new set of conceptualizations and you
thought I was gonna say something really
really really warm and fuzzy but
actually what I think we really need is
a set of fundamental epistemologies and
conceptualizations and I'll try and
touch on that a little bit what I won't
cover in this talk is what generators
are I've given six talks about what
generators are basic efficiencies of why
you want to use generators they're more
efficient than a memory sense or a CPU
sense and some of the deep theory one
thing that I think that we should keep
in mind is Python programmers is that
python is a very practical language it
is not an academic language is not a
theoretical language and so generators
as a construct exist in a variety of
different languages just like functional
programming sync exists in a viable
languages and some languages stress the
theoretical weight of these constructs
of generators or a functional
programming and they go into great depth
with things like monads and transformers
and arrows and Python tends to take
these theoretical tools and apply them
as directly as possible so I won't go
into some of the deeper theory of
co-routines but let me get started one
note for this presentation is that this
is based on these falling future imports
there's a lot of real code in this so
just remember these and this slide got
smushed at the last slide but the first
thing I wanted to talk about was what is
programming and this is where I think we
kind of need to build a better set of
conceptualizations for what we do
because we can sit down and we can take
a problem that somebody asks us to solve
and we can write code to solve that
problem and it's generally effective
like if you come to me and you say I
need to model this financial product and
I have to trade it in this particular
way I can sit down with the team and I
can build an infrastructure I can build
tools to analyze the backtest to to
automatically trade this product and
some results are had but what I'll see
over the course of that project over the
years of developing that software
managing that team is the same
pathologies arise and the same problems
arise in the process and I think that
the consistency of some of the
pathologies that we see in programming
suggests that our way of thinking of
programming is flawed and so the
perspective I come from with regards to
programming my particular religion is
that programming is an engineering
exercise what that means is the real
world has infinite irreducible
complexity and our job as programmers is
to take that complexity to extract
features from the real world that allow
us to make predictions or allow us to
model important things that are
necessary for some business process to
take those features and to arrange them
into a consistent and tractable algebra
that is a set of objects in a set of
operations where we can define into
relations between the objects we can
define the relations and we can induce
we can infer principles from these these
things we can create a system that can
have predictable behavior based off of a
set of unifying principles and then we
employ tools like generators or
functions or classes in order to model
this algebra and so generators here are
merely one mechanism by which we can
actually sit down and encode a pseudo
mathematical model that can be linked to
actually solving the problem I know
that's a little bit heavy but I think
that's the real gist of what we're
trying to do and the real point of
generators so you might say why do I
want to use generators they're too
complex they add too much complexity but
the point here is that there may be
irreducible complexity in the problem
that you're trying to solve and
generators are just one way to express
it and what I'd like to motivate for you
is it generators tend to be a very terse
or parsimonious way to express that
complexity
let me not install my updates during my
talk so to really motivate this point I
want to tell you that your mind has
already been freed and your mind has
already been freed by just basic
constructs
basic concepts and functional
programming it's already changed the way
that you think of code so a simple
example I want to start with just to
illustrate this code is in motion and
that function program is change your
mind is a little report so you have some
data set and it represents the amount of
profit that different regions make for
some company and here you know each
region makes somewhere between negative
4 million and 4 million dollars and it's
random every time that you generate it
and that's more or less how a lot of
large companies work
and somebody says okay printed onto the
screen so you write a little function
here called output and it takes the
input and it goes through each line it
prints out to the screen this is the
simplest code you could write three
lines you're done you go home you know
you watch a TV you go to bed but then
somebody says well look this outputs
really hard for me to read and I can't
see in the line the number they aren't
lined up and kind of suck so you go in
there and you say okay I'll use this
advance string for me this new string
formatting Python and I'll make sure
that everything is left justified you
can see that originally where you had
three lines of code now you have four
lines of code and it's slightly more
complex and now you have things like
look how you have locale based insertion
of the commas to group the digits
because some places group digits group
three digits in some places group two
digits together and the complexity here
has has increased by some amount and yet
you're still not done because somebody
looks at that they say well you know
we're running this code in a system
where we don't have access to standard
out so we also want to write it to a
file or we want to write it to the
screen or we want to write it somewhere
else and so you add in a little thing
that takes in a filename parameter and
now you have this block here that says
if you gave me a filename parameter I'll
open the file and I'll write it to the
file and now the complexity has double I
mean you have twice as many lines as you
had before and all you can do now is put
into a file and you have it nicely
aligned but that's not enough because it
never is enough write this code always
change so somebody says well you know we
want to log this as well so now you
introduce the modality which is if you
have a to logging parameter then you log
it to info using the state the logging
mechanism sub subsystem in the standard
library and so now you can print it to a
file and you can log it and you do a
couple of things you think you're done
but you're not because somebody says
well we want to be able to email it as
well and we want to send it out on email
so you add in a to email modality so
there's yet another motiveless and this
mode says if - email is selected printed
out and also you can see at this point
we can't even fit all of our code onto a
single slide and yet even that's not
enough well this is a 2d mail part you
can see we with a two email there's a
fundamental change in the way that we
write it we have to collect in order to
send the
we have to send it off to a function
that takes the entire body of the email
so instead of looking at it line by line
we have to collect all the lines here so
we have one if statement here one if
statement there and another one down
here that collects all the lines and
calls a function called email that sends
it off and we're still not done and at
this point we we may step back and say
something is wrong with this code we've
added all these little switches and all
these parameters and all these toggles
and yet if somebody comes it asks me for
one more thing I have to the complexity
of this code will just explode I can no
longer maintain this and we reach four
basic approaches and functional
programming to solve this so I'm going
to skip over this slide because this is
something that's necessary for the next
slide but it's a little bit of metaclass
trickery to make this work but you you
you end up it's not that wild but you
end up you end up writing five lines of
code that allows you to capture all the
complexity of those previous 20 lines of
code and you say well instead of taking
all these flags like a do to log or to a
file name or a to e-mail flag I'm just
going to take some function and I'm
going to pass the results of the
function and the function can take care
of things and instead of handling things
like formatting I'm going to have some
template string and I'll pass it to a
template string and you can see with
this example we can encode all the
complexity of the previous example with
substantially less code we could pass it
a function that does the email and log
we can even add additional functionality
we can we can inject additional
functionality into this that we couldn't
in the other one without having to add
more modalities more if-else blocks so
this is an example of how functional
programming has freed your mind frees
your mind from presuming modalities in
that twenty line example you had to know
the modes that you're a functional would
run you have to know that somebody might
ask for you to email it or not that
somebody might ask for you to log it or
not that somebody might ask for you to
write it to a file or not whereas in the
functional approach you don't presume
those modalities you accept the function
you process your data you pass it to a
function and those modes are now the
responsibility of the person who's
calling your function so you've been
freed from having to presume certain
thing certain modes of how that
functions
additionally your API has been
substantially reduced in complexity it's
been simplified dramatically if you look
at the previous example look at all that
the toggles and flags that this took and
all the different ways that this could
work and if you had to test this think
about all the different combinations of
these features you'd have to test to get
complete code coverage because maybe
there's a bug if you do too log equals
true and to email equals false and the
file name does or doesn't exist or is on
a on a different is is a different mount
or something like that there's all these
different modes you have to test whereas
in the functional programming example
you just have to test it when you pass
it a function the results are passive
that function and that function then is
an independent unit that can be tested
as a unit independently from this little
output guy and the API has been
dramatically simplified the amount of
things that this function can do by
itself are much fewer than originally
additionally I would say that pure
functional programming may have further
freed your mind if you've gotten into
some of the more theoretical aspects of
functional programming you might see
that this example is maybe a little bit
degenerate in the sense that a pure
functional programming approach will
tell us we shouldn't make side effects
with with functions I should all be pure
and this allows us to do things like
equational reasoning but I don't really
want to get into that because I think
that just these basic examples show us
that we can implement we can implement a
lot of functionality with just passing
first-class functions around passing
lambdas around and this is something
that we already have internalized that
already works very well for ourselves so
with that being said let's get into
generators and I told you I wouldn't
tell you what a generator is but I'll
tell you what a generator is because
might as well so let's start with a
function this is a function and it's a
really simple function and it has a sort
of a couple of properties some formal
characteristics and some properties for
how it works and how it looks and we
should all be familiar with it this
function gives you the elements of a
Fibonacci sequence up to gives you n n
values of Fibonacci sequence and you can
see functions have one input and they
have one output they may have multiple
paths through that one output but they
have
single input and single output they are
evaluated eagerly so when you call the
function its evaluated and you're done
and in a form of in a formal fashion
because they're eager you have to
collect results if you have multiple
results you have to collect results you
have to do all of your computation
upfront and in Python this means you
have this return keyword and that's what
generally distinguishes a function from
a generator this isn't quite true with
Python 3.4 and beyond where generators
can now return objects but generally the
distinction was the use of return or a
yield keyword and I'll show you another
function this one's called ratio and it
takes another sequence and it tells you
the ratio of adjacent terms and so if I
run this over my Fibonacci sequence we
can see my ratio it goes 1 and then 2
then 1.5 and 1.6 and if I remember from
grade school the Fibonacci sequence
converges to the golden ratio so we can
see this here we have a comprehension at
one part of generators in Python is
generator expressions which are very
similar to list comprehensions a
dictionary and set comprehensions so you
can see what that looks like in a formal
sense here as well and you can see as we
get subsequent terms they slowly
converge to the golden ratio now I think
this is actually kind of neat because
whenever I'm traveling outside of the
United States where people use
kilometers instead of miles I actually
make use of the Fibonacci sequence in
that there are about one point six oh
nine kilometers per mile and the golden
ratio is about one point six which means
I think this is kind of cool
adjacent terms in the Fibonacci sequence
approximate the conversion from
kilometers to miles so two miles is
about three three kilometers - is about
five kilometers and so forth and so on
that's actually kind of useful in my
daily life
if somebody says some somebody some but
you know every time you give a talk in
your way you say I'm X and miles from
home and now I could maybe potentially
sad X thousand kilometers from home
unfortunately being from Texas my
Geographic skills are so poor I really
have no idea where I am right now no no
it's a joke okay so let's get into
generators this is the exact same
Fibonacci
the sequence but implements its
generator and from a formal perspective
you can see instead of a return we have
a yield additionally you can see we're
not doing the calculation eagerly we're
doing the calculation lazily we do each
component of the calculation and those
components are returned as we asked for
them we can see that there is a
potential for there's one entrance which
is you call and construct the generator
object and there are multiple outputs
each time you try to get a value from it
each time you iterate through this
you're performing computation and
getting a separate output this is what
we mean by a coati it's a generalization
of a subroutine and that a subroutine
has one entrance point and one exit
point whereas a KO routine has one and
has multiple potential entrance points
and multiple potential exit points we
won't go into actually we will go into
full color routine to its end a little
bit later in this talk you can see also
very interestingly in the first example
we presume something which is we presume
that you want Fibonacci numbers you want
10 Fibonacci numbers not Fibonacci
numbers up to but not greater than some
number you can see here the control of
which of the values we return is up to
the caller it's no longer presumed by
the person who wrote the library
function so here we use I slice from
itertools in order to pick out the
results that we want to only get the
computations that are meaningful for the
problem we're trying to solve similarly
we can this is an illustration of a very
very useful module and standard library
called inner tools which when combined
with generators can result in some very
very useful helper functions this is a
helper function which I can write from
memory these days called n wise it gives
you pairs of sequence so if you have a
sequence from 1 to 10 it gives you 1 & 2
2 & 3 3 & 4 I use it in every single
thing you can see look even last night
at 3 a.m. I figured out a way to stick
it into this guy here too so it's a very
useful little generator a little tool
and you see I have my ratio as well and
then I can do my fee and all the results
are the same so I think if we were to
try and draw a similar analogy for
generators to what we saw with functions
I went with basic functional program we
can say that generators can free us from
some presumptions about the way that our
code
is used as I said in our Fibonacci
sequence there are different ways that
we could write it if you look at
interview questions sometimes when this
comes up and interview some people say
print the first 10 Fibonacci numbers and
some people will ask print the first
Fibonacci numbers that don't that aren't
larger than 10 and you can see we have
two implementations this is the first 10
and this is the first that don't that
aren't larger than 10 so here we get 10
numbers here and we get the number is up
to 8 but now greater than 8 and you can
see that these two look very different
and if somebody asks you to implement
both of these behaviors you might have
to write either one very complex
function or these two functions whereas
in the generator example your generator
is the same it just yields an infinite
sequence of Fibonacci numbers and then
from the outside you're able to use
itertools these helpers from itertools
to pick the numbers that you want so you
can pick the first 10 you can take as
long as the numbers aren't greater than
10 but you can also implement you can
implement predicates of arbitrary
complexity so what if somebody said we
want you to give me we want to write a
Fibonacci sequence or a function that
yields values from Fibonacci sequence
where you take them where they you want
all the numbers that are greater than 5
and less than one hundred and odd and if
it's Tuesday do this or you know if it's
Tuesday give me the numbers plus one and
in the function you have to do a lot of
work to capture all those different
modes and all those different ways that
your that the computation you're doing
could be used whereas in a generator
example all of those modalities are
exposed to the person who's calling this
function so you can use drop while take
while I slice and here you have all the
Fibonacci numbers in the Fibonacci
sequence you have the first 15 subsetted
by the ones that are greater than 5 and
less than 100 and that would be very
hard for you to encode in this
functional construction
additionally additionally you can think
that because the generator is lazy you
only pay for the computations that you
want so let's say that I have this
little function that does a little sleep
there's a one second sleep in the
generator example if I only want the
first value of this C there's an X range
here 10 right
if I only want the first value I'm only
paying for the first computation I'm not
presuming how much of this computation
that you want and one example that I
bring up a lot that I've seen is I was
dealing with the trading system and that
trading system could give you all the
trades that were done in a book and this
book had millions of trades it was a
very very high volume trading desk and I
wanted all the trades that matched a
particular I wanted like five of the
million trades just the ones that
matched a particular signature but the
way that this had been written there was
a function that was called and I went to
the database and pulled all the trades
and returned them to me and every time I
called it I'd write on memory I would
just try to keep pulling trades and
trades and trades and would build this
list in memory and get larger and larger
and larger and larger and I'd run out of
memory before I even got a return value
from that function to then whittle down
to the five trades I wanted and if this
had been implemented as a generator it
could have yielded values
it wouldn't have produced this memory
pressure and I could have gone through
those computations up until I got the
ones that I wanted and then I wouldn't
have to have paid for the additional
redundant computations additionally I
would say that generators free you from
a lot of other presumptions presumptions
in the way that you encode the problem
presumptions of the way that you write
your code presumptions like what is my
return type in if you have some function
called process it takes some input it
does some something to the input and it
returns some value you might want to
return that value as a list you might
return as a set you might want to turn
as a tuple you can see we have different
ways to to call it we have different
ways that we can write this out and the
first we have a list that we append to
in the second we have a set that we add
elements to and a third one we have a
couple that we append to in Fibonacci
example we have our Fibonacci at written
as a function and it returns a list and
we might have to convert it to a couple
or a set if that's what we really want
and we have to pay for that conversion
as well so you can see there's some
timing here whereas if we were to
implement this as a generator the
generator gives you values and it gives
you values absent any notion of what the
collection type that it's returned so
you can take those values and you can
stick them into a list a tuple or a set
and this can be more memory efficient
because you don't have the pressure of
the two elements of memory at the same
time here if you had a very large
sequence of numbers you need to have the
list of them while you're constructing
the temple and then you can throw away
the list whereas here you're just
getting values you're dumping them into
the data structure that you want and you
can see in this case this took a couple
of times to run before the times really
came to where I want to look like so you
can see in some cases this can actually
be more time efficient to just put the
elements into the data structure rather
than creating a redundant data structure
and then doing a value construction in
the conversion additionally I'm sure
we've all run into code that looks like
this somebody wrote an average function
and it takes a bunch of numbers and they
put at the top if it's not a list blow
up on you and you kind of got a little
bit upset because you had your data in a
couple and it was a really big set of
data and you didn't want to do a list on
the tupple just to make this guy happy
because why does this function care if
it's a list or a temple or a deck or a
queue or any other structure all it
cares is that some works and Len works
right but for some reason they said it
must be strictly less and this bugged
you and you gave it a couple and it
blowed up it blew up on you with a with
a fairly pointless error it said we have
to have a strict list and you might say
well I'm going to be smarter and I'm
going to say since I need some and lend
to work instead of asking for a strict
list I'll ask for a size they'll go into
collections and I'll use these abstract
base classes and I'll ask for anything
that responds to Len and by virtue of
responding to Len that it probably can
also be iterated over and it can be
iterated over the values can be summed
up but this won't work because what if I
have a stream of numbers and you can
give me the average of a stream of
numbers even if you don't have all the
numbers available at the same time even
if you don't have the ability to look
for the length of the numbers and so if
you were to do that this is our even
more generic version of average so
instead of asking for a size or asking
for a strict list you asked for an
iterable all you care is that you can
iterate through these numbers and you
only want to capture two things how many
numbers you saw and the sum of them and
so you can do it in one line if you want
to make your co-workers hate you which
can be a very reasonable thing to do
sometimes
but you can collect you can you can
collect the sum and you can collect the
count without having to hold a memory
more than one of those values at once
and you can return the average and what
this gives you is this gives you an
average function here that can work on
anything that can be iterated over here
you wrote this average function and it
presumed that you need to give it a
couple or a list or some concrete some
concrete collection here you're able to
free yourself from requiring a concrete
collection a collection that exists in
memory at the same time it'll work on
anything that can be iterated over and
for bonus points see if you can figure
out how to write variance it's a little
bit trickier this is an interview
question I've asked people if I wanted
to give a little bit of grief finally
you guys need to you know raise the
energy level a little bit in here so I
mean I may have to go for a couple of
jokes at the end if I if I don't see
more smiling faces in the audience I
will say one of the most important
things I think that generators allow you
to do is to simplify your api's and
remove presumptions about modes in our
foot in our in our exploding complexity
example of printing out this little
report you saw we were adding all these
flags and we were flags upon flags upon
flags and each of these remotes and they
were they corresponded to if-else blocks
in our code and that caused our code to
be more indented it causing it caused us
to have more and more code paths more
things for us to test more area for bugs
it also required that somebody has I
mean my goodness you guys must have used
pandas and how many different toggles
and switches are there in pandas oh my
goodness and half of them aren't even
documented very well and sometimes you
look at the signature that just takes
the star cards and you're like what on
earth can I do with this right the API
is just immensely complicated and you
can see that this is very difficult for
us to meaningfully use because we have
to guess the interrelation between all
the terms another example that that hit
me last night was our parse has all of
these different flags and my goodness
what is the interrelate what are what
are the interactions between all these
flags what does a default flag mean when
you use the append action it can be very
very complicated to keep track of
all of those different things so I'll
show you an example of that
let's here's a very very much a toy
example and a toy example is you have
some source data which is a generator
that yields an infinite sequence of
random values and it sleeps for some
amount of time so it represents maybe
loading from a database or loading from
a stream some process where you get data
and you have to pay for that computation
to get the data and some some process
here that does an averaging of it so you
can see for every data you have you do a
a and you do a averaging of the set of
the data that you have at time and in
this process this this model is kind of
the idea that you have some long-running
process that has some sleep in it that
returns a value and that gives you
subsequent values rather some some some
process that can give you how should I
say this some long-running process where
you may want to look into it and see
where it is along the process or where
it is in its computation because if you
were to run this over a list of 100
numbers you might sleep for 50 seconds
you might not know whether it's
completed whether it's finished whether
it's just started whether it's hanging
you might want to add in the ability to
see where it is you might want to add a
little note a little log in here to say
okay
zero percent of the process I'm 20
percent 40 percent I'm 60 percent I'm 80
percent oh now I'm finally done with all
of my loading and you might realize that
you know you could do that very easily
by just adding a little print statement
here where you print out if you know the
total number of elements you're loading
and you know which elements you're on
you print out something like that so you
can figure out I'm 20 percent through
I'm 40 percent through I'm 60 percent
through and you might also find that you
want to print out some message before
and after you might want to say okay I
started my downoload and now I'm done
with my daughter and we see this all the
time how many times you have some
application that needs to load a lot of
that in the background and it pops up a
splash screen which is your initial
action and updates little progress bar
and then when the splash screen is gone
it gives you access to the application
itself and that's what you might do if
this were a function
and you might say I'm going to use what
I learned in the first part of this
lecture to add the ability to do all
sorts of custom progress updates so all
you all do this in terms of a set of
functions but before function at during
function and after function so when I'm
doing this load data process I'll call
my before function then with each
element I'll call my during function and
at the end I'll call my after function
so here I'll pop up my splash screen
here I'll update the little progress bar
and here I'll say all done ready to use
but you can see this this creates an API
of sorts namely you have three arguments
here and you have to know certain you
have to know certain assumptions about
this organ so they're all functions and
the functions will be called in a
particular order and here if you look at
the way that I've called them I have a
book I actually put the before function
actually use the after function for the
before and before for the after and
there was no constraining me from doing
this or not doing this there's no
nothing constraining me from making this
mistake the API here was too unbounded
there were too many choices I could give
too many different possibilities to this
generators allow us or co-routines allow
us to reduce our API by giving us a
structure B giving us not by giving us a
mechanism that really only has a very
limited structure generator can be
created it can be iterated over you can
send values into it and that's it it's
it's four or less it's far more
constrained than just a bunch of
functions so here's an example with a KO
routine where instead of giving it a
generator you give it a code team and
the co routine enforces a certain
ordering of these elements that you do
the before then you do the during and
then do the after similarly one problem
that I see come up a lot is holiday
calendars and for holiday calendars this
is something this is a holiday Hollander
for Japan you can see they have a lot of
holidays in Japan they take off American
holidays they took off UK holidays and
take off their own holidays it's
probably a fairly nice place to work if
you want to work in the finance industry
and typically the way the holiday
calendars work is that you do some
double while loop here in order to get
the values out and you might want to get
out you know starting from this day
what's the enth business date going
ahead to skipping weekends and holidays
but you could think that if you wanted
the second the one business date off the
second business it off and a third
business it off you're incurring the
cost of this computation this inner
while loop
multiple times you've made a presumption
about how somebody wants to use this
function
you've presumed that they only want to
get one value out they don't want to get
a sequence of all the holidays going
forward and you've forced them to incur
a lot of redundant computations if you
were to implement this as a generator
you can see instead of instead of giving
a strict value you could yield an
infinite sequence of holiday of business
states going forward and then the user
could be could be free to collect these
values as they desire so they could get
you give them an infinite sequence of
business dates starting from this point
and I get the next day the next day the
next date and they only incur the
computation that they need and they only
need to go through this while loop once
now bear in mind there's actually a
closed form solution for this which I
really need to write a talk about but
I'm running out of time already and you
could say if I wanted to make this
example more complex and I wanted to be
able to go forwards and backwards with
business dates I might use where I
learned from the first part of this talk
and I might give a direction which is
actually a function and that function
adds or subtracts time Delta's to either
go in the forward direction of the
backward direction so this is going in
the backward direction with previous
business dates and you might say well if
I want to do something more complicated
than that I want to do business dates
where I rather you can see that the
complexity here is actually already
fairly large and if I wanted to
implement this in a much simpler fashion
you could see that I could actually use
this I could actually create a
combination of two generators I could
have one generator that just gives you
dates going in one direction or the
other and I have another generator that
takes that sequence and takes a sequence
of holidays and gives you the values
going through that and when they line up
when the next date is a holiday you
light it from what you get so let me
skip ahead and you could say that if
this holiday calendar were in SQL
database as it often is and there were
some timing
Cerie in order to actually pull these
values out you have to do a query for
each next row for the subsequent
holidays that you want if I wanted the
next three business holidays I don't
want to do three separate queries to
jump over the same dates with the
generator with the generator formulation
here you don't do that you create one
generator object which has one handle to
the database that only that only does a
query as you asked for the next states
and is able to retain some memory of the
last day to looked at so you can free
yourself from having to incur redundant
computations so the last example I want
to show you is how generators can really
fundamentally change the way that you
write your code here's a function that
calculates the amount of change that you
that you you need to return to somebody
given a set of denominations that amount
so if somebody asks for a dollar and 72
cents and you have these denominations
you give them this and maybe somebody
says this isn't this is this doesn't
capture the problem I want to solve
enough I want to be able to figure out
how much change I give if I if I have a
finite number of coins if I only have
five $1 bills five 50 Cent's five twenty
five cents and so the complexity of this
arises again because now you have to
count how many have I already given out
and you can see our complexity is
exploding here and this may not be
enough because you may find that the
requirements for this may be a lot you
can only give a certain number of
pennies or a certain number of coins if
you haven't given other coins and the
problem can become more and more and
more complex and I'll show you how
generators can allow us to implement
this in a very interesting and very
different fashion think about the
process of counting change you have
choices that you make from different
objects from different denominations and
you pick from the top denomination until
you can't pick anymore you pick from the
next one then you pick from the next one
you pick the next one so you return
dollar bills and you can't until you
can't return any more dollar bills then
return 50 Cent's until you can't return
any more than 25 cents until you can't
do anymore and so forth and so on and
the constraints for how many of those
you return may be that you have an
infinite number of dollar bills or maybe
you have only three dollar bills in your
register what we could do is we could
use itertools to construct this guy and
this is greed what this says is you take
you repeat a certain number of items and
infinite
of times and you take those items while
some predicate is true and then you
chain all of them together to get the
result and what you can do is you could
implement a Co routine here that gives
you that that gives you a result for
this predicate that says you can keep
taking them as long as you haven't
gotten until you until you exceed the
maximum that was set up and with this
you could do something like this where
you randomly generate a bunch of dollar
amounts you have your denominations you
create your predicate and you just
figure out the coins and this is just a
this is just another implementation of
the first one counting change what I
want to show you that's very powerful is
this greedy algorithm is just a greedy
algorithm it's all it is it's just
giving you values by taking until it
can't take until it hits a local optimum
n proceeding and as a result unlike the
original unlike the original formulation
here where we were specified to actually
counting change this code is no longer
specified to solving any specific
problem it could do things like figure
out conversion between Arabic era
between Roman numerals and Arabic
numerals and you could actually solve
any problem that alike that they can be
modeled by this greedy algorithm with
the exact same code and so it shows you
that with generators you have the
ability to create just with just justice
with functional program you have the
ability to create these very simple
abstract but very different structures
that can create code that frees you from
presumptions about return types frees
you from presumptions about how people
are going to use your code freeze these
from presumptions about modalities and
frees you from having to know how the
code will be used it empowers your users
so with that said I think I've run
completely out of time I want to say
that generators have freed your mind I
want to encourage you to all go in peace
and this is how you can contact me
I apologize if I rushed through the last
few examples a little bit but I was
nobody know by virtue of me having
written it I would say well yes I think
so because you can say that sometimes
abstractions can can take you too far
away from solving the problem at hand
but I think sometimes abstractions give
you the ability to do more with less so
even this example is a little bit
complicated you can see that I have a co
routine here called predicate and this
predicate is very very very abstract it
just allows you to define a constraint
function and allows you to just pull
values and you could think that this is
almost a mathematical structure right
it's almost a mathematical construct
where it doesn't really seem to do
anything immediately useful and it does
something at a level different than the
actual level of solving the problem it
doesn't help you count out that change
it's just a piece for solving that so
should you write your code in this way
is a very hard question to answer but I
think that if you were able to write
your code in this way especially for a
library code you might avail yourself of
opportunities to implement behaviors
that would otherwise be too complicated
or too involved for you to implement
with the standard with the standard
approaches I think your question was a
joke but that's a serious answer to
anyone else mafia so thank you for very
nice introduction to generators
you're welcome francese yeah so I like
the concept of generators one thing that
I don't perhaps like that Matt is the
performance I mean when you are into the
data things in Python you typically use
Moonpie a lot right or extensions
written in C and I mean my opinion
generators
always execute in Python space right so
can you say some words about the kind of
performance that you can expect from
generators and if they mix well with
packages like Mumbai or pandas or things
like that so so this is this is
absolutely true if you have some
gigantic data frame and you want to do
operations on the data frame you
typically want to not apply and pass you
what you won't use generators because
you'll want to avoid having to reach
into Python how to run any code in
Python you want to run code otherwise
what I'll say is generators are the
previous talk on generators went over
things like performance and you could
see that performance of a generator it's
not actually that good sometimes you can
write your code naively and it performs
better and that's because sometimes the
overhead of constructing the generator
object itself is greater than just
having a function and calling the
function so in the other generator
example there's actually a in the other
generator presentation there's actually
a me to ipython notebook so I'll show
you in this presentation there's
actually an example of some code words
it's actually works better when it's
when it's written in a very naive and a
very naive way what I would say is
generators I like to talk about
generators as a as a mechanism for
conceptualization because it's a way for
you to arrange and structure the code
and in this in this talk once this loads
up I'll show you the example you can see
so the example is down here where we
have time it you have something that
tries to do trial division to find
Prime's and it's done with little
generator comprehension here and it
takes two seconds and it's done here
with to some run-of-the-mill Python it
takes 1.3 microseconds so writing it
this way is actually much better than
writing in the generator way this is
something that we see the the time to
execute or the time complexity or the
time efficiency of a generator it's not
always that impressive however my
counterpoint for that is generators
force you to restructure your code in
terms of these opaque computational
blocks and the composition of those
computational blocks and they allow you
or they encourage you as a result to
structure code in a way where you can
address performance more naturally so
the counterpoint to this from that
presentation is also that when you get
to the point where you say this code
isn't fast enough your profile you say
it isn't fast enough by virtue of having
constructed your program in terms of
these streams that pass data to each
other and there are these building
blocks you can swap out the building
blocks with implementations with
implementations that are faster with
things written in C and I had an example
of here a way you could swap out the N
wise one with something written in C and
it's hundred lines of mostly boilerplate
so the answer is yes in practice
generators aren't faster than writing
then other approaches but they encourage
you to write your code in such a way
that you can swap out slow parts for
faster parts later as opposed to this
giant mess of functions calling each
other which is what most code seems to
devolve into additionally generators
give you whole whole program information
so a sequence of generators calling each
other they can see each other so you can
you can do optimizations on the whole
program that you couldn't do with
functions since functions are eager they
only see the value outer functions only
see the values of the inner functions
generators will see the inner generators
so you could do optimizations on that
you can have three generation Rho
replace themselves with a generator that
is an optimized fused version of that so
you do ad hoc stream fusion type things
okay thank you sorry I would like to ask
you to ask your questions offline
because we're running out of time so
let's thank our speaker
you
you